so you do Meryl Streep impersonations  correct um so I was thinking like in  prep for like when pigs fly and she  actually comes on my show could you show  me the impression could you show us yeah  close your eyes just okay I'm here yeah  she's here on your show I was crying I  was laughing sorry because every picture  I do see a Meryl Streep she has they're  like most badass glasses on like they're  like they've got to be like a thousand  dollars they're so cute and there's like  a like designer ever yes but what's the  glasses what you're so awesome I love  you're so funny so we'll put this on our  Meryl instapage people you're welcome I  will not stop talking until you  subscribe to my youtube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this